what are you saying I'm a thick neck no
I say your Nikes beautiful it's thin
that's cuz my head is big isn't it Oh
nowhere else to go Andrew Santino has a
new TV show well not yet it's not out
yet but you're shooting a TV showing a
TV show with the rapper named little
Dickie do you know what it is not a big
oh I know I cut that out little Dickies
a rapper that's no dumb ones the rapper
and we do it we're doing a show we're
doing a little show for FX FX bought by
Disney now that's all what is it a
comment ratings' of comedy it's a murder
mystery do you play as manager or
something yeah it's a comedy i plays
best friend really mm-hmm
well congratulations that's a big deal
yeah I mean we'll see yeah I hope it
does well we haven't shot we start
shooting in August you have a go to go
from I'm dying up here to that oh you
wait that long in between you weren't
you were very busy between the two
things yeah a lot of stand-up stuff but
like we talked about at lunch TV
sometimes scares me because I don't know
if you have no control yeah absolutely
no can stand up I have all the control
oh I guess you have all the control what
else he showed me Bobbi's phone went off
by the way in the middle of the taping I
couldn't [ __ ] believe it I couldn't
believe it either but Andrews showed me
this thing I never knew existed
this is so funny that he didn't know
this everyone and this is so basically
it's basically the sag AFTRA right yeah
and then you punch in your password
right and what it does is this like
everyone in the business knows what this
is
no because here I know I don't know
anyway you're talking to people who
don't know who have no idea this means
nothing to people that are listening
sag-aftra is a union for actors and this
just tells you how much money you're
making a residual right I see I'm gonna
tell you why because I don't know how
much money I ever make because all my
checks go to Clinton my guy those don't
go to your guy those go to your home
no they go to my guy your residual
checks don't go to you no bad bad bad
bad bad
yeah bad bad bad bad bad why does a man
get your residual check he's he's my guy
but anyway um and I don't just who is he
he's my accountant business manager yeah
does he send you a breakdown every month
what you what he gets in no cuz I told
him not to but what it what it shows
here what checks they mail do you have
one of these yeah and then like and then
what's in the process and I thought I
never look at look at this one you'll
still get [ __ ] from a long
yeah he got one from what what do we
find
there was mad TV on there whoa there was
wasn't romantic there was no mad TV on
there actually to be honest video we're
Haledon kumar was on there Harold who
was on there but I got to find this
other one that was interesting to me oh
sorry sorry guys
well don't you know sorry I'm trying to
find uh sorry you so much Adam saying he
loves us so much
sorry I just said sorry who said that oh
[ __ ] Adam egit because I Harold a
little boy who could I said this is text
Adam II get and I said hey what a bomb
I'm so sorry and then he sent me just an
atomic bomb going off that's what I did
that can't be good
how did I perform so I I didn't think I
made any movie I did Harold and Kumar 17
years ago yeah and this month I made 32
dollars in that wild on something I did
Seto Randers ago I did two episodes of
this is us and I still get very large
checks once in a while I was so [ __ ]
popular yeah
it's beyond popular yeah two degree that
like I go places and then when I'm
talked to about it from an industry
standpoint they're like how amazing was
that and I was like was just I mean it
was fun I like it wasn't I'm not on the
show yeah yeah but they're obsessed with
the show so they're like what's it was
it like that for you and I'm like well
no I just I just whacked it on it yeah
yeah I went home how was that onset was
that not know what well I I think we
talked I think I talked about it on here
try out do I have a one question though
is that young when you walk into a set
like that do you believe that they know
that they're on a good show the second
season yes the first season they didn't
know Ron I did the pilot episode of the
I did a first episode of the second
season and I did the second or third
episode of the first season I knew I've
said this multiple times on a billion
everything I knew that show was gonna be
a hit I know that's like a cheats like
how do you know I knew I was like wow
this is pulling on all the right
heartstrings the table read made me tear
up
it was so good oh wow it was so good
that I was like wow this is really smart
and clever and different and unique and
then when I did the episode they were
all happy as [ __ ]
sweet Milo's the [ __ ] Mandy's the [ __ ]
they're all nice P
yeah and in the middle of it all they're
kind of like yeah this is come this is
great you know by the second season when
I did the first episode they knew who
they were but they didn't act different
they were just like I was like dude this
is incredible and they were all like
yeah man we're [ __ ] they were they
were on high yeah by the way because
everybody on that show everybody on that
show is a lot of accomplished actors but
like nobody had had a in a long time
yeah Milo had been on Gilmore Girls
he did he did one of those things where
it got big and then but that was a while
ago and he did a bunch of other stuff
Mandy Moore did a bunch but like never
really so they were all cool and had a
lot of humility
it was wild man but you fitted her I've
been on sets where they act like they
know what they're on that wasn't that
show yeah I've been on plenty of shows
where I go around and they're like
thanks for coming back
[Music]